five Chad
[Music]
vibe check I need a body check right
here vibe chicken or else I'm gonna burn
your toes off here's a pro tip for you
gamers before you buy someone's head in
with a baseball bat just Yelp vibe check
it's passable in any court of law at
least in the 52 States officer I was
simply committing a vibe check on this
fellow man well very well
feel free to go vibe check by check
understandable have a great day sir
before you kill someone's minecraft dog
brought in the vibe check listen I'm not
saying that Abraham Lincoln's murder was
justified all I'm saying
he probably checked his vibe I'm not
saying that john f kennedy's murder was
what they did a vibe check on a
pedestrian what too far society too far
PP on pedestrian bruh vibe check now i'm
not saying that as as a villain but a
very big vibe check was committed you
ever got your anal vibe checked I have
that's all I'm gonna say
vibe check failed I have sleep sleep I
must vibe check yeah you don't want to
fail a vibe check trust me on this one I
guarantee you one of the few things I
can guarantee you don't want to mess up
a vibe check it's gonna be painful
the first vibe check can be traced back
as early as 2003 3 where it's featured
Mike Myers live act interpretation at of
cat-hat
I can't read help me no this is
factually incorrect
we have vibe check in many different
mediums that happen before that in guns
chapter 208 where the samurai did the
vibe check on the girl and you have
failed the vibe check Oh God
never fail abide chains this is gonna
become a meme for people to beat each
other up I like it Bob check by Jack
don't make me ever
check your vibe check privileges you
have failed vibe check on my god is that
the final form of Bionicle that is
hacking cooled oh-oh-oh Bhama snake
wants to look at my vibe I don't think
so
go and file your taxes vibe chick vibe
chick oh ok so it does come I'm pretty
sure that's for people with diabetes but
vibe check you seem to just be chillin
show me your vibing license immediately
handover your vibe license stack vibe
chick failed
[Music]
I'm not gonna lie I'm just surviving I'm
just chilling right now five check he
was just checking her vibes sir the
ancient Egypt even did it as well
amazing Bob check gets a vibe checked
good job
next ma'am this is ma'am review by the
way name review Roley
[Music]
gradient memes have you heard of a
douche have you seen this another scam
app that will charge you a monthly fee
to check if you look like someone here
you have a picture of a dog eating bacon
looking like Ryan Gosling Thank You
gradient what would I have done without
you here you have Kanye West looking
like what No ah my vibe is not vibing
right now I'm not gonna like how how
Obama looking like Obama oh yeah
Obama go back and file your vibes I bet
he wants us to pay taxes for our vibes
now doesn't mean here you have a gas
villager looking like my Watson I always
thought they look alike I'm not gonna
lie that slowly leaves the Wi-Fi
coverage area the Wi-Fi quality no snoop
d-o-double-g freak yeah gamers I always
knew it I always knew it jared leto
looking like yeah wait what oh cool one
punch man looks like me good to know
Thank You enemy very cool Fidel Castro
ironic you look like Michelle Obama I
always knew it I always knew it the
Madagascar penguin looks just like
Michelle Obama I've said this for very
long time a very long time you can track
it back to the ancient hieroglyphics
I've always said it Obama wife
Madagascar penguin you look like the
Senate
all right I'm trying to think this one
isn't real
you look like we need a boat I know it
Thank You gradient very cool but what's
that we just came in a news report Pew
News gradient ace indeed bad in China
you look like queen margrethe ii you
taking the piss their gradient I mean
not gonna lie though they look kind of
similar anymore did it first though game
where it's not gonna lie and I think
they did it better
you look like tree Wow
and now I'm not gonna lie that Scarlett
Janssen looks just like tree wow you
look like kim jeong-hoon wow you look
like kendall Jenner I agree 100%
you look like Stephen King is it weird
that they had the exact same nostrils
like they pick one part and they get it
completely right so I can't like I can't
lie down bet I bet Stephen King is
vibing right now I'm not gonna lie
what what what why this app is really
good it was nice knowing you
here it is you look like Tobey Maguire
you look like Tom Holland but how does
spider-man look like what how could we
have been so blind you look like Mark
Zuckerberg Oh his name is Farah quash or
something oh my god you look like
William Willem Dafoe you and I are not
so different they do look similar it's
so weird
stop stop it beam review this meme gets
a zero I don't like it wait then I just
give it an actual number this meme gets
that okay
next mean
[Music]
there's been an update to the jomama
memes I don't know have you heard about
this have you guys seen about this
there's a couple more good ones all
right
hey baby yes you know Joe baby it was a
one-time thing
I promised your mama wait what wait what
wait what did you hear what happened to
Joe who's Joe Joe mama me tisha was shot
by Joe mama using ball mama bruh forgive
me I did not see here's the new one
Jerrod yeah you know URI yeah
missiles armed and ready sir locked on
target
ready to fire you're [ __ ] god it's
literally like four kids yo hi
do you know Candace if she related the
Mike no she's Joey's brother
I thought he passed away from legmen no
he's still he's still alive he lives in
snug on these I thought that place got
renamed to Sigma yeah I think so it's in
Russia where Yuri lives who's Yuri dodge
this you're [ __ ] BAM
alright gamers like
I feel like put the way this might bully
hunters will get these harasses where it
hurts them the most
by beating bullies at their own game
that's right
we've been here for the past four hours
recording everything you think you can
eat flame dude did you give you the
homework
I don't watch anime bro the girl IRL in
your class Yuri Yuri stupid no it's your
turn but Barbara hey want to hear a joke
yeah sure [ __ ] I don't get it I know
[Music]
good haha you got me but guess what I do
have Joe who's Joe you're [ __ ]
[Music]
you're [ __ ] me say Mike hoochies
Harry my couch is Harry
Mike cheese Harry my kuchi he's saying
Mike Rowe cheese tenet use alota Brina
lotin ha mimin first we need a merc new
minimally usury yen part Baker comes in
all right guys that guy was awesome but
little candle and let it's me little
you're [ __ ] meme gets a zero alright
Bing memes me searches people dying
Google here's some fun tie-dye shirt
designs
Bing bridge jump is badass me types
anything not good related Google stop it
get some help
Bing bling blong yourself Amazon deals
you will love frequently bought together
you can get a great deal on ladder in
rope you are welcome our algorithm can
tell that a lot of people like ladders
and ropes my father searching for
parenting advices Google traitor
childlike human person and respect their
rights Bing just beat it Bing is so
freaking epic Google be like leafy being
be like idubbbz
MRI gamers me how to make TNT Google
Bing
this is literally it where do you start
something on you want to find out in
mine cry although if you don't know how
to make dynamite in Minecraft shame on
you me how to earn money Google five
honorable jobs Bing the secret
ingredient is crime what you want to do
here is you want to steal stuff
me trying to help myself from doing bad
Google I got you I got you brother
Bing oh no you know you know how to
settle a divorce Google Bing how how do
I collect the debt from a friend use
absolutely no pressure just like an
Angels wing Bing beat the devil out of
him kick his [ __ ] ass get your
friends and some lighters and burn his
nipples off search his way of committing
bad there's some good in this world mr.
Frodo
and it's worth fighting for Bing so you
have chosen why is being so terrible on
Google Bing why Google Wow Wow
how to purge a baby to sleep at Google
why being Dutch there being Sun you dang
it dang it and well I'll get my
Microsoft phone and tell girl being a
lady thanks meme there's a couple more
Joker means then I don't know I like it
okay I like Joker me looking at my name
three hours later realizing a spelling
mistake oh my god
with Korean exchange students add you to
their League of Legends team yeah hey me
wins a game of cards on my PC solitaire
Oh bad and so get no 9 year old niece is
a security camera also 9 year old me yep
why do they always show you on the
camera it's awesome I love it
Pumped Up Kicks melody Pumped Up Kicks
lyrics oh yeah no because the lyrics are
so edgy mom me with a weird light save
I found under my mom's bed me with the
light-up spoon that I found in my
parents house after visiting 20 years
later huh class clowns at school class
clowns at home this says a lot about our
society teacher gives out a homework the
homeless kid well I never thought of
that
that's so awesome lucky homeless kids
all right final me you better not be an
eastern town sound gang because then
you'd be like it's getting pretty late
better go to bed yeah
go to bed Eastern time zone gang
pathetic made by central time zone tag
destroyed America time gang be like
howdy y'all I want a hamburger this post
is made by Greenwich Mean Time game
that's right
eat [ __ ] America time gang Greenwich
Mean Time gang is where it's freakin at
bruh Greenwich Mean Time gang be like
bro it's almost 5 p.m. Pt spies about to
release a video Greenwich Mean Time gang
Fu Central Standard Time this mean was
made by Eastern Standard Time know
Central Standard Time gang got
completely destroyed Western times don't
be like I can't play video games yet I'm
still at school llama made by central
time zone gang yeah man yeah man no man
imagine living in 2018 this pose is made
by East Coast gang pathetic
a set is the center time we can hear you
from the mother flippin future New
Zealanders be like made by Central
Standard gang oh oh shoot dog it's two
hours later than PS time PST time time
to go to bed this may this me was made
by Pacific time zone gang
imagine having to get up an hour earlier
La Grange sprout Mountain Time Zone gang
be like help I'm being mauled to death
by mountain lions
you stop my god is Mountain Time Zone
gang okay oh my god are you in mountain
time zone gang run run you fool run this
meme was made by Pacific Standard Time
Zone GMT - seven gang damn which gang
you're part of gang member
America losers be like it's 5 p.m. here
but a p.m. here sorry bro
can't play fortnight to with you mom
wants me to go to bed
all unify under one timezone glory -
proceeding pain
glory to one time's up we must unify the
nations glorious one time zone the world
is better if we're less segregated and
all United one time John is better
imagine not living in the centralized
time zone this post was made by GMT gang
[ __ ] GMT gang Oh imagine being the
central focal point of time [ __ ] G and
teen gang babes Pacific time zone gang
be like yeah it's noon my face when she
says she's from Central Standard Time
fish
I ain't freaking no [ __ ] from central
time zone gang fish get the Frick out of
my sight I could get in trouble if
people know that we're associated with
each other it's gonna be a lot of bang
Vaughn central time zone cringe that's
what you could be call central time zone
always my time central time thought it's
what I'm calling it from now on
alright gamers this has been me review
bad can you please stop screaming it's
just video game also dad during football
games
[Music]
yo that cab was awesome but check this
out Wellum say no man alright guys hope
you guys enjoyed this episode of meme
review unless you're from central time
zone gang just leave just go don't want
your stinky face here smash like
subscribe check out the mug check out
the merch nerd VPN the figurine I have
first chair G fuel and have a great time
until I'm back tomorrow see you guys
tomorrow
like have a good time enjoy - hi don't
forget to enjoy life because otherwise
it will pass you by and then you'll be
like bruh where life go that's right we
do meaningful [ __ ] on this channel all
right I gotta ended
Oh
[Music]